consult your apocalypse handbook and
book your tickets to Siberia because
it's episode 9 of American Horror Story
apocalypse and I needed this episode
like a nail to the head seriously after
last week's episode it's good to see
this is stepping in a better direction
it begins looking down the barrel of a
gun as Jeff toils away at the sexy hand
robot we saw work its magic last episode
and you can see that Starbucks look like
coffee has actually spelled his name
correctly every time he clicks so does
the gun and no wonder he's pissed the
Wi-Fi was down this morning and he had
to wait five whole minutes for his
coffee mutt tries to cheer him up but it
isn't helping
Jeff Mets down land menteng about
traffic and asking all this needs to end
he's referring to humanity in general
not to mention he's having doubts about
Michael whom he calls the lost
Antichrist last episode which I thought
was the weakest of the season so far
spent its entirety showing how Michael
was lost without resolving how he'll
find his way this episode rectifies that
mutt reminds him to show some respect
he's the son of Satan after all well
Satan might want to get a paternity test
you are not the ha
Jeff is sick and tired of waiting
Michael owes them a world worth the hate
and mutt tries to calm him down saying
that even Jesus needed time to sort out
a [ __ ] he's referring of course to when
Jesus spent 40 days and nights in the
desert where he also met Satan the world
is [ __ ] and they need to burn it down
wipe the slate clean and start over
they're interrupted by Venable and you
can even make out some sick pinball
machines here in the back she reminds
them about their meeting with a
cooperative who we really haven't heard
from since episode 3 the co-operative is
the organization that Michael works for
who were responsible for the apocalypse
venable wants to know who or what
exactly this co-operative is she asked
if Michael's a member in Jeff lightbulbs
perhaps they can introduce Michael to
the cooperative and together they can
finally get [ __ ] done Venable chastises
the two saying she should be given more
agency because she spent all her hard
times solely for this company she's not
getting the respect or power she
deserves also noticed that she's wearing
purple if you remember all the way back
in episode 1 Venable tries on a purple
dress which she's not supposed to do
Purple's are only designated to the
elite who paid their
a in the bunkers mut tells her there's
an old saying if you aren't where you
want to be just look in the mirror again
another nod to Episode want they dismiss
her because she has more important
things to do like order those mile-high
escorts she's had enough and tells them
she's done here but Jeff's idea about
Michael must now come to fruition back
at the coven Mallory attempts to raise a
bird from the dead similar to what she
did with the dough earlier on in the
season Myrtle and Cordelia tell her the
reason it's not working is that she's
exhausting herself she needs to give it
time and it's time that they don't have
we learned this takes place after the
burning of Miss Mead when Michael told
them he'll come and murder them all as
long as they stay in the coven Olive
Robichaux will be protected by
Cordelia's or a shield any human demon
or other will find it impossible to get
through the doors zoe gives a lesson on
controlling the energy around them
energies can take the form of emotion
spirits and toxic people the key to
understanding such energy and defending
from it is a Guardians chalice a trap
for the bad energy which needs to be
used in conjunction with a mantra the
power will then get sucked into these
jars filled with rusty nails and blue
gems Dinah as queen of Voodoo performs
her own ritual outside the steps of
Robicheaux cutting herself with blood
and ruining their nice hardwood patio
apparently her ritual breaks Cordelia's
protection aura and Michael enters with
robot mom Michael confronts the witches
and is given a warm welcome yo when Zoe
takes matters into her own hands and
jettisons the nails right into Michael
but Michael goes all neo from the matrix
and completely obliterates the witch's
meat steps in and Queenie loses her [ __ ]
Mallory Cordelia and Myrtle hear the
screams from downstairs while Queenie
uses her power which we haven't seen her
used this season using her body as a
voodoo doll on Mead but of course this
doesn't work since Mead is a robot
Mallory wants to help but she's worn by
Cordelia and Myrtle that there's nothing
they can do
Dinah asked that Michael be a man of his
word apparently they made a deal in
exchange for Michaels entry if you
remember from episode one we learned
that Dinah was a famous talk-show host
now we know how this was her dream and
she paid for it in blood Michael
ventures upstairs to finish the job but
the remaining witches have escaped back
home Michael exclaims that they've
failed seems Michaels held on to his
mother's home because this is the same
satanic kitchen area where Michael was
raised by Satan Mead Mead tries to
console him claiming that this was still
a victory the best is yet to come when
the world will reign with fire we then
learned that Jeff and Maude are watching
the conversation through me just like
how Michael used me to see what was
going on in the bunker in episodes one
two three furthermore they can control
what Mead says trying to influence him
to end the world because ending the
world would mean ending the witches but
we know that isn't entirely true since
they end up surviving the apocalypse
Michael says he could run for president
to take over the world but Mead calls
him out because that's exactly the plot
to omen three haven't you seen that
movie is it any good leave a comment
below after another quick hit of the
devil's dust they try to get Michael to
come back to them there they can
influence him to get in touch with the
cooperative they passed him a list of a
hundred of its members like Putin and
Bill Clinton and we learned that
cooperative is just a name for the
Illuminati a secret society often
alleged to conspire to control world
affairs by masterminding events
implanting agents in government and
corporations in order to gain political
power and influence to establish a new
world order since everyone in the
co-operative has sold their souls to the
devil he therefore controls it
they don't need magic to take over the
world they can just use the shittiness
of humanity genocide and bombs baby also
extra points if he caught the actual
human here posing as a robot but
explains the next step is to trigger
dead hand a Russian nuclear defense
system which was created to ensure
mutual assured destruction if it detects
a missile another will be
and retaliation automatically even if
the commander's in charge are dead
the remaining witches hide out in the
secret swamp Shack where Cordelia astral
projects to find the witches back at the
coven disappear on her she couldn't feel
their souls and therefore was unable to
bring them back it was likely that she
was performing dissension here which we
saw Mallory and Michel successfully
perform earlier on the season Madison
pipes up and informs the crew about
Michael's ability to erase people's soul
which we saw him do in murder house
Cordelia pimp slaps Madison furious that
she withheld this crucial information
myrtle steps in saying none of this
fighting will bring the girls back she
pulls out an ancient tome and tells the
others about Tempest infinitum or
eternal time whoever has his power is
said to be able to change past events in
alter history leading me to believe this
will be how the apocalypse is eventually
reversed and who has this power Mallory
of course if she was able to harness
this power she could change time and
save the coven there's just one teensy
little problem those who have attempted
it have died trying
Cordelia draws a bath and Myrtle tells
the story as were transported to Siberia
in 1918 four months before the end of
World War one to be exact
a young woman anastasia is startled by a
commotion in the hallway and her father
tells her they need to be moved into the
basement because of the danger of nearby
fighting she tells her family to grab
their things and they're led to this
creepy basement to be shot for their
crimes against the Russian people but
Anastasia uses a protection spell only
to find out her powers aren't strong
enough now I'm like why the hell is
Myrtle telling Mallory this grim story
this is like the worst pep talk ever
apparently they need her to know it so
she can go back in time and save
Anastasia as proof she can do it Mallory
must put herself in a different state of
mind and focus on the jewel using it to
place herself in a siberian basement
Cordelia and Myrtle chant as Mallory
farts a bunch in the table and is
transported to Siberia now I don't know
how Anastasia knows English but I'll
just chalk it up to witch magic or the
fact that maybe an elite Russian at that
time might have known it but the plan
seems to be working until it doesn't and
they're all stabbed and shot to death
Mallory returns from the worst bath of
her life and is consoled by Cordelia
it's only when Cordelia confides and
Myrtle that she says the only way
Mallory will be able to successfully
pull this off and reach
height of her powers is when she has
passed in other words if Cordelia dies
the coven can be saved and she has a
heartfelt conversation about her mother
Fiona who only put herself above the
coven which is juxtaposed with Cordelia
who puts the coven before herself she's
distraught not sure what the right move
is but Myrtle is doing a great job at
lifting her spirits but it's not enough
for Cordelia they must invoke the sacred
taking a ritual in which her powers will
be transferred to Mallory but this would
result in her death the fact that
Cordelia is willing to kill herself for
the greater good
speaks bounds about her character Myrtle
and Cordelia pay a visit back to the
bunker to enlist the help of John Henry
and behold every bit of help can slow
Michael down but behold they're dead
back at Koch headquarters Venable packs
her stuff when Jeff and mutt returned
her letter of resignation in fact they
agree with her she can't possibly work
for a company that won't be there when
the planet ends they offer her a job
working for the Illuminati which she
thinks is silly not silly it's full
meals but mutt explains the co-operative
have designed outposts for the right
people and let me tell you if the people
in these outposts are like mountain Jeff
well humanity if he damned anywho the
outpost need people in charge of them
and who better than the trusted miss
Venable not only that she could make up
her own rules and if you remember back
to episodes one two three this is
exactly what she does remember how Tim
and Emily like remember Tim and Emily
the characters we spent like three
episodes with and then we never hear
about them again because they super
advanced genetics and they maybe come
back in the next episode and be the
thing that changes everything oh my god
I gotta shut up remember how Tim and
Emily weren't allowed to have a
relationship because sex was forbidden
this wasn't a cooperative rule that was
a miss Venable rule in this scenario if
she wouldn't have to answer to anyone or
anything she'd be the boss which we find
out isn't truce and she eventually comes
under the power of Michael who controls
the co-operative Michael holds hands
with his mom and these delightful red
gloves but has second thoughts about
being able to convince the co-operative
to go through with his plan Meade gives
him the best pep talk a mother can
telling him this is what he was put on
this planet to do to destroy it
Michael addresses the leaders of the
co-operative who looked like they're in
some crazy ridley scott kink film and
tells them he's the Antichrist with a
wave of his hand he commands their
attention telling them the time
has come to wipe the slate clean it's
time for the apocalypse because these
influential members have given their
souls to Michael's father they have no
other recourse than to obey but fear not
their families will be saved in luxury
fallout shelters and with his final
words Michael turns their attention to
these Handy binders so that the plans
for the end of the world
can eventually take place I'm so excited
for the finale guys in my opinion this
season overall has been better than the
last view and hopefully we'll get to
find out what happens in the current
timeline the one we left off in episode
4 I'm also thinking of doing a promo
breakdown if I have the time so stay
tuned for that and if you like this
video make sure to LIKE and subscribe
also since the season is winding down
make sure to give me suggestions on what
shows or movies to do next either in my
comments or on my Twitter page and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much